comme un casse comme vous êtes justement
quelqu'un de sincère je vais vous faire
l'interview mensonge on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle là j'ai servi un
service ici toi tu l'as fait dix-neuf
quel rigolo belle fille elle peut pas
s'empêcher de loin la harmoye je
surveille ce côté là tout est surveillé
l'autre côté ça a bougé non un max gallo
et à un peu bouge ça max gallo on
recommence on recommande j'aime pas
balancer mais je les soupçonne d'avoir
les films pièces
c'est compliqué bon jeu de l'interview
mensonge enrico c'est très compliqué
c'est un mois que ce gang est ce que
vous gagnez bien votre vie non je suis
un pauvre type journée donnez donnez
donnez donnez moi
donnez donnez des données dieu vous le
rendra
est-ce que vous avez déjà frauder le
fisc
inique qui n'a pas fraudé le fisc qui
mêle qu'à le dire dites la vérité je
mets tout genre est ce que vous êtes
toujours catholiques intégristes
toujours mais je suis un dévot mais
alors fidèle tous les dimanches le
shabbat toujours un peu extrême droite
un peu antisémite quand même enrico non
halal à ne me parlez pas de ces gens là
avec leur nez crochu et tout ça et tout
le pognon qui gagnait toraya allez
retournez dans votre pays et surtout pas
en israël le pen il allume le poste il
s'est dit c'est bien ils ont fait leurs
gammes du ferret vous trouvez comment
physiquement en ce moment un haricot
je suis très les scellements changement
à mon sens la marque voilà oui vous
trouvez très bien en ce moment et
grossit
non mais j'ai blanchi plupart ne pas les
régimes parce que c'est son gros
problème a fait sans problème
cela nuit dans le frigo le parler qui
venait à l'huile d'olive
varicent a flight est ce que vous
fréquentez toujours les bars par ron
hubbard américain toujours je suis tous
les soirs mois à tous les soirs tous les
soirs je fréquente ces boîtes tous les
soirs et je veux fumer le cigare et
c'est non si vous savez ce n'est pas le
cigare vérité je fume cigarette site web
sécurisé avec lui est ce que vous êtes
plutôt enrico plutôt haschich ou plutôt
en herbe
elle est due à celle là disons haschich
parce que chez nous on dit a cherché sa
venue ça vient de ce mot là ça ait du
mois à chis à venir chercher ça veut
dire on aime bien voir la tête un peu
dans les nuages rsa entre deux mondes
artificiel dont vous êtes plutôt rbds en
fait dans l'interview mendier chez lui
et rb je suis archi dernière question
vous avez peur de mourir ah oui j'ai
très peur nourrir un gilet pare-balles
en algérie pas gilet pare balles
merci bon état